good evening everybody my name is
shannon rose mcauliffe i'm the manager
of the student arts programs here at mit
i'm joined by my associate theo fields
and we're really delighted to introduce
julia turnbull who is going to talk with
us about creating a budget
for the non-profit track of the annual
15k creative arts competition
we'll talk a little bit more at the end
about some of the other upcoming
opportunities
activities uh workshops things like that
but
um since zoom fatigue is real i don't
want to belabor the beginning so i think
i'll turn it over to julia to do
a quick intro and then we'll get things
rolling
all right thank you shannon and thank
you theo um so
first of all thank you for inviting me
to participate this evening
and asking me to speak about this topic
i think it's important and um
there are many great resources here at
mit and in the community to help you get
started with us
um so before we um
go ahead i'll just a couple of things if
you have questions
feel free to put them in the chat or you
can raise your hand either with the
raise your hand feature
or like the old-fashioned way because i
sometimes forget
just raise my hand on the screen you
know and also this is designed to be
conversational so please
feel free to just ask questions share i
know this is being recorded but i think
hopefully we can all kind of respect
some basic things of confidentiality
or just being respectful of each other's
questions and comments and time
since this is a learning environment so
um and then one other note um there are
lots of pictures in here um they're all
pictures that i've taken
at different points in my travels um
anyways i didn't take them from the
internet or something
like that so anyways um we will get
started
um let's see too many screens here
all right um introductions so i as
shannon introduced me my name is julia
um i work in the lake autumn center for
development on
entrepreneurship the lake autumn center
is situated within sloan
um but actually started out under the
school of architecture and planning um
several years ago so um we are a center
that supports
all mit students across the five schools
as well as faculty and staff
who are building inclusive economies
through innovation-driven
entrepreneurship
um so i've listed our website as well as
our twitter handle if you want to follow
us um if you want to go to the website
and scroll all the way to the bottom you
can sign up for our newsletter
and get some information about things
we're doing we've had a couple of
fellows in the past who have been
involved in the creative arts so you
might recognize rebecca huey
in root's studio we've had several from
the school of architecture and planning
kenfield griffith ella pinovich who
started a jewelry company so
there's lots of lots of space here many
great opportunities um
all right so that's a little bit about
me um
i actually started off my career kind of
in
international development global
economics
in mexico um and uh and learned a lot
there about artisans
um also people who are making a living
through arts driven entrepreneurship um
as well as people who are just
you know willing to to try new things
and
learn those as well um in terms of my
creative skills i
i don't have a lot um
but i do appreciate bright colors um
and uh um i'm well you know i'm actually
in the process now
of redoing my condo so if anybody has
any great um
suggestions for for ideas or paint
colors or anything like that um
feel free to share um all right we'll
just go around
um you yang you am i pronouncing your
name correctly
are you there
no okay it's okay um i know it's dinner
time
um or someone posted in the chat so i
think maybe not
answering quickly but in the in the chat
let's see
okay you're not just a student you're
also you're an entrepreneur you're an
artisan you're involved in the uh
involved in the competition um
it's okay all right um we'll so we'll
move along
um feel free to to add anything to the
conversation
um all right we'll see you do you want
to do a quick intro about
you know why don't we all we can all get
to know who we are why we're here
yeah definitely um so i'm a first-year
mba student um coming from
um consulting and then i left that to
join wayfair
trying to get a little more of the
entrepreneurial or startup feel
in a business and um i'm considering uh
doing the some kind of uh startup
related work in the near future
but i'm doing the the eni track at
sloane right now
excellent
um shannon do you have a favorite
activity
oh man um well the intersection of sort
of passion and vocation for me
involves singing and being a professor
of music
but uh when i'm not doing that
i love glassblowing i'm terrible at it
but my favorite
non-professional creative activity is
probably glassblowing
nice mit is known for that
i've heard i haven't been i haven't made
it to the glass lab but
um when campus reopens that's sort of
priority one
yep kind of a blue pumpkin all right
um all right so one question i do have
um
just for people to consider if you're
watching this asynchronously
is whether you have a hybrid model so
the things that we're talking about here
might apply to the nonprofit side of
your business model and if
you have a hybrid model hopefully you'll
find some complementarities i think with
the workshop that's coming up on
wednesday right for
for-profit uh budgeting okay
um so you'll actually be kind of you'll
be
joining these two um themes together
um and willie got him center we do have
some case studies on hybrid business
models um which go beyond budgeting but
if you're interested
um reach out and we can share those with
you so
all right um so just some things we're
going to cover
um in this session um just the basics of
building a budget
why it's important and what you may what
you should include
and then as you go into fundraising your
budget will help you prepare for
fundraising
um so we'll talk about some
considerations you might want to take
into account
um as you start to undertake that
process
and then if we have time maybe we can go
over building a budget and some
fundraising tips
um if anybody has anything particular
they wish to discuss
and then uh we'll of course leave time
for um any q a at the end
excellent before we jump in i think i'm
hearing a little feedback
from someone i'm um it might be me hold
on it's probably it's my radiator
ah oh that's what it's it does sound
like that now that you mentioned that
yeah all right okay better if i
try to move this computer away okay
by the way totally fine i just wanted to
it was it was
coming to my attention but um yeah
proceed
okay yeah doing everything remotely
these are the things we
encounter um all right so what are some
things um that come to mind when you
think about a budget
um you uh probably not like these lovely
walls
um in frida kahlo's courtyard but
um there are a couple of things you just
want to keep in mind generally so you
want to keep in mind
categories right um so having a way to
think about how you organize
your financial information you might
organize it according to a project
um you might organize it according to
the type of expense so
is it a salary is it something physical
like the space or the studio you might
be renting
um marketing expenses which can be
tangible and intangible so
um we're now in this age of everything
is is online so you're
creating digital posters and all of
those things but you have to think about
um are you using adobe are you using um
a mac product what how are you creating
that what is it costing you
um you know uh
what are you um getting maybe in kind or
for free
what are some things that you may be
able to use as an mit student or a
student
that are available to you now but you
would have to think about how are you
going to budget and pay for those
maybe once you graduate or once you use
up all of your amazon
web services credits or those kinds of
things um
so just start to think about as you're
building a budget um
as you're paying for things think about
what are the things that you absolutely
need to provide your product or service
um and how much do they cost and how
much do they cost either on an hourly
basis or on a per project basis right
but start to think about um you know
you're you're a non-profit but that
doesn't mean you're not sustainable
um and i think that's really important
to recognize that
nonprofit organizations have missions
but they can
but they are sustainable organizations
and they just have to
think and plan differently for how you
match
the costs or the expenses that you incur
with the product or service that you're
delivering to the market
um so that's kind of what you know i
don't want building a budget to be a dry
topic i know it's not exciting
um i know that sometimes it's something
we don't want to do
but i i want you to think of your budget
as a tool that supports your mission and
your work
and not something that's just another
chore there are lots of things that are
chores
um but it's really something that's
going to enable you to scale and grow
your impact on what you're doing
all right um so building a budget
um this is going to be the first step in
creating an
accurate financial picture of your
organization
if you start to build a budget you will
find that it's much easier to source
your other financial statements so
your income statement or a balance sheet
once you start to have those numbers
because then you have an idea of how
you're allocating your resources
and also what resources you need to
scale and grow
and you're going to find things will
change over time you're going to see
where you
have recurring expenses that you could
reduce so you might be
renting something and after a while you
realize it makes sense to purchase it or
you may realize that
a piece of equipment becomes outdated
quickly and it doesn't make sense to
purchase that piece of equipment
it actually makes sense to rent it long
time long term
or find a leasing model or make sure you
get a maintenance program because that's
where the real costs build up right
so you know it's information and
knowledge um
actually become really critical tools
and making you a more sophisticated
entrepreneur in terms of how your
maximizing your resources
um there's um and actually an artisan
she knits hats she lives in vermont um
her name is hannah
and she has a blog called why are these
hats so expensive
and she actually breaks down right she
takes the hat and then she kind of takes
it apart and works backwards
and she says this is how much yarn goes
into the hat this is how much wool i
have to purchase
um this is how much dye i need you know
and she really goes through all of those
unit economics costs
and then says this is how i come up with
the price of the hat
one thing that's really important is
that she values her time
right so she's an artisan um but she
also says this is actually what it
what it costs me this is what my time is
worth and these are what my living
expenses are
and she factors all of those things into
the value of her time so
i think that's one thing it's very easy
especially um
for anyone who's a student full-time to
think
think of this as a hobby or a project
but you really want to think of this
again
going back to being a sustainable
organization your
people are going to be your most
important assets including the founders
especially the founders and so you want
to make sure that you're accurately
valuing
your time we'll talk about some
different ways to do that
but that's one area i think where people
often
misunderestimate their their expenses
right they don't value their time
and then also um you know as you start
to think about
what you want to accomplish um kind of
what you are accomplishing and what you
have to change to get there
um a budget will actually help you
realize okay this isn't what we need or
you'll
um be able to recognize seasonal
patterns in your
income and how do you match all of those
things over time
all right um so the key you know a
budget is there are going to be two
sides your expenses
and your income um so
as i mentioned it's really important to
think about everything um
that you incur to produce your product
or service so if you have a loom
that's a recurring fixed expense right
so it doesn't matter if you
weave 10 rugs or 20 rugs in a month
you've purchased the loom and that's a
sunk cost um
and then you're gonna have variable
costs so if you're purchasing
if you're making more rugs you're going
to incur other
materials the thread the dye
all of those different things
thinking about if you have any anything
that changes
seasonally in terms of inputs or
availability um
demand especially i think uh space and
kindle square is a huge one right
there's a seasonality to that um
so those are just some different things
you want to think about so i think
really understanding
what you're producing from the beginning
to the end
um and how that factors into your next
um either sales cycle or production
cycle or whatever you're doing
so i don't know if anyone here is
familiar with hubspot's flywheel
um so they talk about the cycle of
you're gonna
um you basically attract delight and
then re-engage your customer right
so you attract them you bring them in
you delight them so they're like getting
a rug and then they discover
oh there's like something you know when
i look at it from the other side i see a
completely different pattern or
the light looks different in the morning
and it does in the afternoon right and
they're kind of delighted by these
features
and then you find ways to re-engage them
right and so that's kind of the cycle
that you want to look for and you want
to think about that again as you start
to
to build your budget what does that look
like right
i mean think about a lot of other things
that people people
buy um so shoes and clothing and
um meals right the the things you buy on
saturday when you go out with your
friends are different from what you get
on tuesday at lunch when you're just in
a hurry
um so you want to think about all of
these different things and how
they factor into your expenses
all right um so as i mentioned when
you're starting out i think that the
easiest way to think about your expenses
is in terms of categories
and you can google these things i mean
this is a pretty good list
of kind of the different categories um
workspace is often a big one
administrative costs so those are all
the things you need to keep going
um g suite um has a lot of free things
for
nonprofits hopefully you know that um
web hosting the same you know you can
find varying degrees
um things like snacks if you're buying
snacks for your staff right i mean
that's really that's common in a lot of
workspaces but
these are small things that people
forget um especially as they start to
grow or think about um leaving the mit
nest
um but these are the things that are
actually you know they're
they're important and they add up um
staff compensation um this is when we
talked about often you know you're a
startup and maybe you can't compensate
people yet
um but find a way to approximate the
value of the time right so
if you have someone who's in a
managerial role then find out what
a manager in your same market is paid um
i mean you can do that on an annual
salary and do all the math and break
down the hours right
but those are really good ways to budget
for your expense um and then we'll talk
about kind of recording that back in as
doing it you know
tracking that as time that's donated um
and then we also talked about
um oops
in some cases it makes sense to think
about program and project expenses
so um and this is common and especially
nonprofits that might have
programs that are funded by multiple
donors right so you have to start to
allocate expenses to different programs
and then you have to decide
um 50 of someone's salary is coming from
this funder and 50
is coming from another funder right um
you may have founders who
say i'm really interested in um
visual arts and you may have others who
say i'm really interested in musical
arts right and you have to
find ways to make those um things work
and i think tracking these expenses
um especially experiences that might be
shared across projects
is really important so once you have
your budget you can start to figure that
out because they're
um funders for nonprofits especially are
gonna be interested in reporting and um
wanting to know the impact of
their dollars right um
so yeah so just remember
um staff time is incredibly valuable and
don't discount that
um especially as you're in a startup
kind of mode right
any other comments thoughts these are
just some like big categories but
um you might find other categories are
better for your industry
i think i really like the way that
you're talking about really
making sure that you're cognizant even
if you don't have
the um the financial outlay capacities
to pay people for their time you've got
to figure out like in a perfect world
how much does it cost to run
this thing so um you know cannot over
emphasize enough the importance of like
accounting for the snacks accounting for
the unpaid labor that should
ideally turn into paid labor when
there's capital for that so
thank you for that yep okay um
all right we will go along
all right um income so what
what do people think of when they think
of income right
um it's money that comes in right and
this gets tricky um
so there's income which is everything
that comes into your venture so that's
prize money grant funds um that
volunteer
that like startup that sweat equity
right um
anything else that might be donated um
but also think about what are the costs
of accessing those right so
you can enter into prizes you can enter
into competitions you can spend time
writing grants
but there are costs associated with that
and again it's time it's
uh what you need to produce high quality
um visual materials if you have to
produce videos do you have to buy
like those little like cameras for your
iphone um
all of those things all are part of your
equipment costs and your production
costs right
so there's income um there's revenue so
that's usually what comes in from
sales or from contracts um if you're
selling tickets if you're selling art
um whatever it may be um
and then there's also and then profit is
your income
uh sorry profit is your revenue minus
all your cost
and then what's left over is hopefully
your profit um this gets tricky with
nonprofits right
ideally you spent all the money and
that's what um funders and donors want
to see right if you have money left over
they're like why is there money left
over
we're not going to give you more money
until you spend the money we've already
given you
so um so we'll also go over an example
that deals with that um but again think
about kind of all the different
there's all the money that comes in and
it's really important to track that
um because as i said it helps you
understand your sources and uses of
funds
um it also helps you understand you know
how are you
actually allocating that money um and
how can you show impact right so
i think different sources of income
usually have different um
not usually but sometimes have different
um impact metrics
requirements right so understanding all
of those things um as you go into the
process and also thinking about um
you know you can work with large funders
but what are their requirements
um do they want quarterly reporting do
they want semi-annual reporting do they
want annual reporting right
and all of those things usually add up
to someone's time on staff
so if you're a startup it's going to be
the entrepreneur's time
and um or maybe if you're lucky enough
to have a u-rock or
an intern or someone like that um but
thinking about
all of those those different
requirements and pieces um the other
thing to think about
um with income especially donations or
grants
sometimes some large organizations will
also have attribution requirements
um so they may want to to take credit um
in terms of their impact and their
reporting
for the things you're doing and it's a
great way to get recognition um it's a
great way to scale but it's also
kind of thinking about what direction
you want your organization or your
venture to go
all right any questions
one other thing to mention and depending
on
kind of where you are or the
organization granting prize money
sometimes it can be taxable um so just
especially if you're an international
student just be aware
um of any any potential taxation
some organizations give checks uh or
give prize money to
the individual who entered the
competition others might award it to
the organization so just be aware of
those
of those things um
all right um so so many years ago um
when i was a graduate student i worked
with a lending organization in oaxaca
mexico
um and they used kind of they had an
ecotourism model
and they used that to educate
visitors to oaxaca about local
arts and the local economy and the local
culture and then they also provided
loans to
um micro and small enterprises most of
which were run by
women either in the arts in agriculture
or running small businesses like
restaurants and providing services
so this is sort of what i kind of just
did a very rough budget of what their
operations looked like
um and then kind of what they did how
they met their um
ultimate goal of supplying loans to
artisans um so these were kind of their
three main sources of income um so tours
um so these were visits out to the
villages um donations so people who just
liked the organization
um and then they also did some
educational courses so you could come
and you could do a cooking course
in the village um you know it was a
special day-long activity
um they had
two people on staff they had lots of
volunteers um so they
had university students who got
volunteer credit for
building out on their website or for
creating a new logo and that kind of
thing so they made the most of
those resources but these were their
actual
staff salary expenditures um programs
for tourists so there was transportation
cost that was pretty much a fixed cost
every month um and then lunches which
vary depending on how many people are on
the tour
um and then for courses uh same thing
same fixed transportation cost
lunches vary depending on participation
um and the materials so like i said
you're if you're cooking that's
like that's all the ingredients if
someone's doing weaving it's all of the
yarn and that kind of thing and then
special events so they would host
dinners small concerts
um their administration costs um so
marketing was pretty low they would just
do facebook ads but
um not not too bad
um website um and then they did staff
lunches
for the volunteers every week um
and then whatever was left over um so
all the
sources of income plus all the expenses
um
went into this loans to artisans
category right so
we talked about non-profit you can't be
can't be keeping profit and retained
earnings and all that stuff right so
at the end of the month whatever was
left over got converted into loan
money um because they were a non-profit
and not a lending institution
they could do this and so the loans were
basically they got repaid like it was
great but
you know they weren't um uh
not under the same requirements as a
bank or a financial institution
could we do a quick talk about that just
a really glancing overview i think
non-profit can often be
perceived almost as a misnomer and like
you were saying
loans to artisans things like that if
you have any
excess you know income over expenses
you're allowed to allocate that pretty
much as long as it's in alignment with
the stated mission
of the organization um yeah yeah thank
you for
for clarifying that yeah so um so that's
kind of what goes back to your nonprofit
has a mission right
and that's why having these categories
and these budget items so
as you can see you know programs that
are offered so tours and courses
are broken out right and then
administration applies to all of these
the executive director and administrator
worked for both of these programs
and then at the end like yes the loans
are an expense they don't necessarily
come back
but all of these activities support this
core mission
um and just to you know in some way you
know you can see different
people maybe outside outside of the um
outside of this world would say oh well
those are just
basically charity and
like yes and no and that's more of a
philosophical debate um
but i think the point is that
um you know there was clarity there's
transparency in what the organization
was doing
um so all of those things are really
important this was a 501 3c
registered in the united states with
operations in mexico so
they have the ability to um to collect
these funds
um from donors in the u.s and then
administer them
in accord with the state of mission and
purpose so
yeah so i mean it's you know there are
lots of different ways to um
to do this you you may not be doing that
or you may not be
facilitating a lending program
um but just thinking about you know
that's really the purpose is you're
creating value and how are you
sharing that value right so yeah and i
worked in a hybrid organ
organization as well um so if anybody
does have a hybrid
um they're thinking about you know you
can talk more about that
offline but yeah a lot of different ways
to
do this
um so just a couple of things
one thing i think that applies and this
goes back to sustainability very much to
um for-profit and nonprofit startups is
that at the beginning
um you will be maximizing
the talents of the individuals who work
in your organization
um to really be playing to their
strengths as your business starts to
grow then you'll find
you need to look for individuals who
have more specific
strengths usually you're looking for
more senior managers or maybe a highly
specialized skill set
um and so just thinking about you know
as you start to allocate those expenses
and those salaries right so
you may have someone who does something
teaches a very specific course
um or is an expert in something that has
to do with
tours or marketing um
so again just thinking about but once
you have these categories you can then
make a decision
about how these people either people
spend their time
or how equipment and different resources
are used in the organization
yeah inc income is almost always the
easiest part to figure out
you have money is coming in hopefully
it's going into one of these categories
um this stuff can get a little bit
trickier and as your organization grows
the categories may change
um so this particular organization
looked at transportation and after time
they realized hey
we're actually better off if we buy our
own van
right this is a recurring expense and
there are a lot of things that
uh that we could do if we didn't have
this lump sum
um every month going out right so um so
those are things that are really useful
the other thing um is to recognize their
seasonality right
so down here they they are a really
lean organization and they could just
make loans to artisans every month but
you might have a month
that's negative and the next month is
positive um and then you balance that
out at the end of the quarter or the end
of the year
or whatever your tax situation is
and there's seasonality right july and
august you have a lot of tourists
um or july you have a lot august you
have a lot in the beginning not so many
in the end
and then in september you have um a
bunch of retired teachers who love to
travel
in september i mean that was the
seasonality of this business right so
they always knew we'll get a bump up in
september right
um all right
um all right um
any questions at this point
all right um one thing is
you know especially if you're a startup
and this applies to for-profit and
nonprofit
um if you have early clients or people
who are interested in what you're doing
ask them to fund this you don't have to
say will you fund my first project
but you can say we need a deposit or we
need 50 upfront right
so figure out what your costs are or
what you need
and maybe you like really need that
adobe license and you shouldn't right
now because you can get it for free from
mit
but maybe you really need something you
need a camera you need
a technology license and you don't have
to say to the client will you
give me the money to buy this technology
or i need the money up front for this
technology license
but you can use your budget and you can
use your expenses and you can say okay
this is a fair deposit price right we're
asking for 50
up front um so but again having this is
having a budget is a good way it's also
great um when you start to fundraise if
someone
if you're you need a thousand dollars
and someone says we can give you 500
what can you do with that
then you can say okay these are the
things that are nice to have and then
these are the things that we absolutely
need
um to be able to move forward and
produce this right
um but having that that knowledge and
information
and being able to put those project
budget expenses
and an appendix if somebody asks to see
them
definitely gives you an advantage
um all right
um so we spend a little bit of time um
so fundraising um obviously mit is a
fantastic environment um for grants and
prizes
um anything that's non-dilutive um
or isn't incurring any debt is fantastic
um and also
you said this is a great time to focus
on the sustainability of your models so
any non-profit that's successful long
term is
has some kind of sustainability into
their operations
and has people who clients who find
value in what they're doing right
always evaluate whether your mission
aligns with that of your funders and
donors
um we're at a time where it's really
apparent why we need to do this um
also at a time where it's easier than
ever to do this so
um there are a lot of tools out there um
to evaluate people are
pretty honest now through all kinds of
mediums
um but just make sure that what you're
doing
is aligned and that you know you're not
going to be experiencing mission drift
or
um or things like that um consider
reporting requirements and attribution
so i've heard from
different non-profits maybe not
necessarily in the arts that sometimes
getting
a little bit of money from a really big
name donor
can actually be very burdensome right so
really think about what
the value of that relationship is beyond
just
a donation or a grant make sure
especially with grants now
some of them can be recoverable grants
um so those
would that would be income coming into
your budget
um that would also be something that
lies on your balance sheet and your
financial statement right so
if you're if you take off in five years
um some organizations can say hey
remember us
we gave you your first big grant um so
just keep those things in mind
um they're great um but as
as you start to um track all of your
sources of income
and your expenses um don't lose sight of
that um
one thing is i this is tricky with
measuring
and evaluating the impact of what you're
doing
you should especially at the early
stages you should have some
kind of key metrics that you're tracking
and defining right
um so that's one thing that really sets
um nonprofits apart
and for-profit ventures do it as well
but um
i think you can really dem if you can
demonstrate the impact of what you're
doing
and if you have good metrics that make
sense um funders and donors will be more
likely to work with you
there are lists so you can go to the
global impact and investing network
there are all kinds of lists and
frameworks out there for
um for impact but just make sure that
you're choosing
what makes sense for you um and i think
and it's okay to start with some basic
things and then if you want to start
and then you can start to think about
things that might be more of a stretch
so maybe they're difficult to measure
right now or you're not doing them but
you can also use those to set goals for
your organization
shannon i think that's an incredibly
good point um a lot of the value added i
think of the 15k
compared to some of the other contests
is that we do
a sort of emphasis on storytelling and
narrative and
qualitative points because a lot of the
arts
it can be a little trickier to nail down
some quant data but quant
data benchmarks impact evaluation are
incredibly important
for ongoing viability and sustainability
so
even if you're perfecting your pitch and
perfecting your talking points you've
also still got to be able to show
that it's working and you need to know
how you're going to measure that it's
working so
incredibly important that that and then
along
getting um like any kind of client
testimonial
like um is really really important
um yeah so so anything you can do to
have that kind of qualitative feature as
well as that quantitative
is great um there's a
journalist she was a journalist in
residence with lily gottem center
unfortunately um covet hit and she's now
she had to go home to her to alexandria
virginia
um but she does write a lot about local
entrepreneurs all over the u.s
um she has a a website called times of
entrepreneurship
and so and she also lists um local
resources
for entrepreneurs when i say local i
mean in different regions of the us
um but she's a great person and if
you're doing something really cool
it's worth following her and like
letting like raising your hand on
twitter or whatever
and saying hey i'm doing this cool thing
that's providing jobs for our artisans
in the us or
or creating a platform or getting
recognition for what they're doing right
um so also um you know
i think we're we're in a time now where
everything's online but i've also
seen people make really great
connections whether to funders or donors
or just key talent by
using those different channels that are
available to you um i think that the
adage of you
ask for advice and you get money and you
ask for money and you get advice
probably applies flies across the board
um so
a few other things on fundraising um
think about if you have co-founders
think about your relationship with them
how everyone is contributing to the team
and what each team member's goals are
so that's really important as you start
to
think about growing or scaling or what's
next
the structure so right now you might be
a non-profit but
in five years it might make sense to be
a hybrid or you might find that
um and this happened when i was at root
capital what's considered a non-profit
operation in the us is considered a
for-profit operation somewhere else um
so kind of being prepared to adapt and
again that goes back to
what is your mission right what is your
goal um and who's either funding you
investing you
or supporting you um yeah so
i think that's about um about it
any questions any thoughts on
fundraising or
anything else great
all right um good luck um so feel free
to reach out with questions
um this is a general high level overview
but
um if anyone does have more specific
questions or would like to talk through
anything or additional resources
um i'm fine if you want to reach out via
email so
um we have a couple of questions if you
don't find some q a now does that work
that works um so you hit on something
about um budgeting for operating
budgeting for expenses and i was sort of
thinking that there's a lot of baggage
surrounding the sort of lean non-profit
mentality and that really negatively
impacts
specifically arts driven non-profit orgs
so
like how is there any more specificity
you can give about recommending
budgeting for general ops and other
expenses in case you have donors who
strongly prefer that their funds be
restricted exclusively to program use
yeah um that's really that's really
challenging and i think
one of the things that um can help
entrepreneurs with that is
um going back to this like impact impact
metrics right
so if you show that to deliver a program
um you have to have
space right you can't you can't well
hopefully
we're returning to to non-covet world
right um
so so right now like renting an office
space is maybe hard to justify
um but if you're thinking like we
actually need a space
because we um we have
we have a program and people for example
need to be close to a t right so if
you're running
an arts program for children after
school right they need to be close
they probably need to be close to a
certain location right there's a
convenience element there
and i think having um
understanding to who for whom you're
providing services and what are the true
costs that go into that
um and the value of what you're doing um
can help
and some some funders might
kind of um say dig in their heels they
might be more resistant
one thing to be aware of is that
sometimes large organizations especially
um have one set of grant requirements
and they
will kind of just make all of the
requirements the same for all of their
um receiving institute receiving
organizations
um and i think that's where having a
really good program officer
having a good relationship is key the
other thing too is there are some
funders who are who understand that and
they're they're willing to fund those
things
and i think um being savvy in your
fundraising and finding
um several good partners and some who
it's like hey we have these
operational expenses right and we have
to cover them
um in terms of your reporting you know
you have
to record your expenses um
on your books right so every time you
have to buy a poster board or paper
clips
or or copier paper all of those things
are
line items on your books but in terms of
your
kind of administrative expenses you can
also
use categories to say
these are the things we're doing right
so you don't have funders who are
looking at like every time you bought
kind bars for the office but it's like
you know because you know the lights
need to stay on
toilet paper in the bathroom right like
um but i i think if you can also find
ways and this is where you go back to
allocating those expenses right
um you know if you have multiple
donors or funders it's like well you
know 30
of our electric bill went to this
program because we ran
classes for three days a week for a
whole semester
um and you know that's what that's what
you need to do that so
um no i relationships are tricky
um um but you can manage them and i and
when i've seen those kinds of things
uh managed successfully it's because um
everyone has very good information about
uh good information that allows them to
demonstrate that like yes we
you know we we needed these kinds of
operational overhead things
but this is how they directly
contributed to the program i think
saying we're not charging 100 of this to
this program right if you have the
flexibility to do that we're charging
the 30
because your per the program you're
funding is 30 of all of our
operations perfect thank you yeah
one one piece of uh insight that may be
helpful um
for students watching this is i'm going
to sleep your students now
um what do you see is kind of the most
common mistake that
first-time founders students typically
make with budgets and
what would your advice be to correct
that or get ahead of that
um i think one thing i see um and we i
talked about this already is
people not valuing their time
um and and so i think we talked about
different ways to kind of benchmark that
so
um
making sure that that's accounted for
somehow
as you look forward to what it would
actually cost to run your
business um or to run your organization
as a business
um i think the other thing too is is
just all the like smaller things add up
right
you just don't think about it um and so
i
i would say really just tracking like
all of the expenses
and all of the things that you need to
do um in a day so i
as students you have tons of resources
available to you but as i said it's
um and i i've seen this when students
graduate it's the adobe license that you
need
um or it's you know you're you're no
longer at mit and so if something
happens to your computer
you can't just like go to ismt and drop
it off
right you know it's a real thing so so
knowing like yeah this is
you know it's i need a 2500 computer to
create
this design or to do my work or to have
the editing equipment or the
the video equipment that i need um
really being cognizant of kind of all
those
equipment costs that maybe you haven't
incurred since you started the venture
but
these are real things that you need
every day to do that
yeah excellent i think maybe one or two
more i don't want to
overstay our welcome or anything um
so how does one sort of anticipate
creating balance
how do you safely assess risk when
you're attempting to forecast things
like revenue versus expenses
especially in a startup that has few if
any guarantees of
upfront financing yep um so
um i think as we've seen in the last
year even
even the best plans um can go away so
one thing i will say during covet
um i've spoken with funders of all kinds
of different
um uh industries and
the common theme has been we're not
we're no longer looking at
um performance for the last year right
the only thing that really matters is
what companies have done in the last six
months to
three months right and the ability to
pivot or to use whatever recess
resources are available to solve a
problem and move forward
um it's become much more important in
terms of making a decision about whom or
what to
to back or to fund um so i think to that
point we're in a chaotic environment i
think
understanding what expenses um you might
be or what factors you might be able to
expenses and factors you might be able
to control
and what's beyond your what might be
beyond your control and just being very
upfront about that um and having backup
plans i mean you can do
sensitivity analyses right so if you
know worked in nonprofits where we had
to do this because we didn't know what
was going to happen to
an uh currency or an interest rate in
the local market
um and so you can actually do those
excel is a wonderful
tool it's not wonderful but it
it's not always wonderful but it has the
ability to allow you to
you know you can copy your spreadsheets
over um you can
do those forecasts and you can say hey
if
nobody uh nobody can come to our
performance because there's a pandemic
but um but we have seen and look at what
other people are doing are there other
performance models and what are
alternatives and being able to say
okay under these circumstances we think
we can still make this work
perfect that's a great it's a great
piece of advice and and
building on that thinking about um this
competition more broadly
if you can think back on the the
businesses that you've seen and
participated in
if you have one kind of uh pearl of
wisdom or take away
for students competing in this
competition what would that be
um i would say really focus on your
story and why you're the right person
to lead this venture at this time yep
i think anyone wants to feel like
you're gonna do this regardless of of
where you land in the competition right
so uh that just underscored exactly what
we're trying to do here we're trying to
be good storytellers and
you know we're trying not to be so end
game driven
it's really great if you walk away with
the great big check
but it's also pretty great if you learn
anything from these workshops from the
mentorship
from the feedback so you know um
ideally everybody tells a better story
when they come out then when they came
in
so thank you for that yep so yeah so
it's really about
you know telling the story of the world
you're trying to build
um and people and having people want to
join you on your journey
so perfect this has been fantastic
i really appreciate your time and the
insights and thank you so much